this is a brief history of anonymous
[Music]
greetings to the people of the world we
are anonymous in this day as we speak
there is a revolution brewing
it started with 4chan though you could
go back even further to to Chen or
perhaps the Situationists and maybe even
before then let's start with 4chan for
Chen is a place for sharing images like
I Can Has Cheezburger x' and lolcats
there's also a dark place on 4chan kalbi
this is the unofficial birthplace of
anonymous here in the murky world of
anonymous postings trolls brown eyes and
pissed hey artists are the so called
beat hearts they like to lol so much
they created the world of the laws one
of the first actions was to rick roll
which seeded a web with fake links and
the ped all bare but that's enough said
about that there was also the attack on
the Epilepsy Foundation that's right
some menon's hosted flashing gifts to
their web forums to cause migraines and
epileptic seizures like we said they do
it for the lulz even when the walls are
cruel then there was the habbo hotel
raid in which a froude avatars blocked
an online poll saying the pool was
closed due to AIDS there were hundreds
of lossy raids and then a long Came
Scientologists Tom Cruise how could they
pass up such a perfect target cruise is
definitely good for a laugh
operation chanology was born anonymous
began to escape the internet a network
of anti Scientologists spread across the
net and at street demonstrations after
chanology came WikiLeaks leaked
diplomatic cables from the u.s. spread
across the internet compliments of
WikiLeaks collateral murder was released
the video shows civilians in the rock
gunned down by the US military US Army
Private Bradley Manning was accused and
arrested for leaking the video to
WikiLeaks Claire
then came the Operation Payback
and Operation avenge a senj more ops
began to spring up during the Cold Arab
revolt since anyone can join anonymous
the anons were now truly legion more ops
followed including operation Tunisia
operation Egypt operation Bart
there were hacks on law enforcement
denial of service attacks then there he
was operation Sony and Occupy Wall
Street who knows what ops will follow we
are anonymous
expect us
[Laughter]